>> Sean: THE DESTROYED TRUMP
MEDIA HAS BECOME TOTALLY
UNHINGED OVER THE RAID OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S PERSONAL
ATTORNEY MICHAEL COHEN WITH SOME
GOING SO FAR AS TO QUESTION OF
DONALD TRUMP CAN TAKE ACTION IN
SYRIA AS A DISTRACTION LIKE THE
MOVIE "WAKE THE DOG."
>> THE NEWS DOES NOT COME MUCH
BIGGER THAN THIS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAITING MILITARY
ACTION AGAINST SYRIA.
THE FBI TAKES ACTION AGAINST HIS
PERSONAL ATTORNEY AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP LASHES OUT BIG
TIME.
>> I'VE BEEN REMINDED,
PRESIDENT AND FICTION DECIDES TO
START A WAR TO COVER UP FOR
HANKY-PANKY.
REAGAN, PEOPLE THOUGHT HE
STARTED THAT ACTION AND GRENADE
OUT TO COVER UP FOR BEIRUT.
>> WE HAVE A TEMPERAMENTALLY
UNFIT MAN WHO IS NOW HAVING TO
MAKE DECISIONS ON WHAT MAY BE A
DECISION THAT NOT ONLY IMPACTS
THE FUTURE OF SYRIA BUT THE
ENTIRE REGION.
>> THIS SERIOUSNESS OF THE
SITUATION WITHIN THE WHITE HOUSE
IS INTERESTING AT THIS TIME.
HE WANTS TO DO A "WAG THE DOG"
IN SYRIA.
THE TIMING OF THIS.
>> Sean: HE ANNOUNCED THE
THREAT OF A POTENTIAL REACTION
WITHIN 24, 48 HOURS.
JOINING US NOW, AND OUR ATV
CONTRIBUTOR FORMER
SECRET SERVICE AGENT DAN
BONGINO.
RICK UNGER IS WITH US.
OBAMA, YOUR FRIEND OBAMA, THE
ONE YOU LOVE SO MUCH, RICK, GOOD
TO SEE     SEE YOU.
YOU'VE BEEN A STRANGER AND YOU
HAVE ABANDONED OUR PROGRAM.
>> I AM BACK.
>> Sean: YOUR TOTALLY
ABANDONED US.
>> I HEARD DAN BONGINO WAS HERE
SO I HAD TO COME BACK.
>> Sean: OF COURSE.
OBAMA DREW A REDLINE IN THE
SAND, DID NOTHING, AND IT'S ONLY
EMBOLDENED ASSAD.
JOHN KERRY ANNOUNCED TO THE
WORLD HE GOT RID OF 100% OF HIS
CHEMICAL WEAPON ARSENAL.
NOT TRUE.
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT TRUE.
THE RED LINE RESOLUTION WAS
SUPPOSED TO INVOLVE THE U.N. AND
RUSSIA GETTING THOSE WEAPONS OUT
OF THERE.
CLEARLY THAT DID NOT HAPPEN.
YOU ARE RIGHT ABOUT JOHN KERRY.
I CAN'T ARGUE WITH YOU.
EVEN WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP DID,
WHICH I SUPPORTED.
>> Sean: DID YOU GET THERAPY
SINCE YOU'VE BEEN HERE LAST?
DID YOU GET HELP?
>> I JUST TELL THE TRUTH.
YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT.
>> EVEN WHAT HE DID DID NOT
APPARENTLY GO FAR ENOUGH.
SOMETHING IN SYRIA.
WE CANNOT SIT BY AND LET ASSAD
DO WHAT HE DID TO THOSE POOR
PEOPLE IN THAT SUBURB OUTSIDE OF
DAMASCUS.
HOWEVER, ALL OF THAT IS NOT
GOING TO STOP MEDIA, LIBERAL OR
OTHERWISE, FROM SEEING A "WAG
THE DOG" SCENARIO.
I HAVE A SUGGESTION FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
CONGRESS, SENATE IS LOOKING AT A
NEW BILL THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
INTRODUCE THURSDAY TO RE-SET UP
THE WAR POWERS.
IT'S A REPUBLICAN SPONSORED BILL
IT'S A REPUBLICAN SPONSORED BIL
BILL.
IF I WERE THE PRESIDENT IN THIS
SITUATION, I WOULD DISCUSS IT
WITH THE CONGRESS.
>> Sean: BAD IDEA.
HE IS THE COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
>> CONGRESS HAS THE POWER
ACCORDING TO THE CONSTITUTION.
>> Sean: BUT EVERY, NO
PRESIDENT HAS LISTENED TO THE
WAR POWERS ACT.
>> THEY SHOULD.
>> THE MEDIA, I KNOW YOU GET
THIS BUT THE AUDIENCE NEEDS TO
UNDERSTAND THIS.
THE MEDIA UNDERSTANDS AND SEES
EVERYTHING WITH REGARD TO THE
DISDAIN FOR TRUMP THROUGH THE
RUSSIAN COLLUSION LENS.
EVERYTHING.
THEY HAVE BEEN GAS LIGHTING
THEMSELVES WHEN THEY TELL A LIE
OVER AND OVER.
THEY ISOLATE THEMSELVES FROM THE
TRUTH.
WHAT THEY SEE HERE IS THEY SEE
THIS AS A "WAKE THE DOG" EFFORT
DESPITE THE FACT THAT TRUMP HAS
BEEN HARSH ON THE WEAPONS PRETTY
WIPED OUT A BUNCH OF RUSSIAN
MERCENARIES IN SYRIA.
HE'S BEEN BASICALLY TRYING TO
BANKRUPT THEIR NATIONAL GAS
MARKET WHERE HE SANCTION SEVEN
RUSSIAN OLIGARCHS WITH DIRECT
CONTACTS WITH PUTIN.
THEY ARE LOSING THEIR MINDS AND
THEIR DISDAIN FOR TRUMP.
IT'S COLORING THEM TO THE
REALITY IN FRONT OF THEM.
IT'S REALLY EMBARRASSING THEM,
NOT US.
>> Sean: ARE YOU GOING TO
DEFEND YOUR LIBERAL FRIENDS IN
THE MEDIA, RICK, EVEN THOUGH YOU
ARE BEGINNING TO SEE THE LIGHT?
>> YOU CANNOT BLAME THEM, SEAN.
IT'S UNREALISTIC TO THINK THEY
ARE NOT GOING TO NOTICE THE
POSSIBILITIES HERE.
>> Sean: DIDN'T TRUMP
UNANNOUNCED 24 TO 48 HOURS
BEFORE WE HEARD ABOUT THE RAID
ON MICHAEL COHEN'S OFFICE?
>> YES, HE DID.
BUT LOOK AT WHAT HE ANNOUNCED
THE WEEK BEFORE THAT.
THE WEEK BEFORE THAT, THE
PRESIDENT SAYS I'M GETTING OUT
OF SYRIA.
THEN A COUPLE DAYS AFTER THAT,
IT'S WELL, MAYBE NOT SO SOON.
>> Sean: 24 TO 48 HOURS, BY
THE WAY, I WISH WE WOULD RAID
THE DOJ AND FBI AND GRABBED
THEIR COMPUTERS.
>> YOU GOT THE TIMELINE ALL
MESSED UP.
HE SAID WE MAY BE GETTING OUT OF
SYRIA.
THEN THE GAS ATTACK HAPPENED AND
THEN THE COHEN RAID.
YOU HAVE THE WHOLE THING MIXED
UP, RICK.
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
HE DID SAY THAT BEFORE THE GAS
ATTACK.
PEOPLE LIKE ME WERE GOING WHY
ARE YOU GETTING OUT SO SOON AND
WHY ARE YOU ANNOUNCING IT WHEN
YOU ARE THE ONE --
>> HOLD ON.
THE QUESTION SEAN JUST ASKED.
JUST CALL OUT THE MEDIA AND SAY
ALL RIGHT, THIS IS OBVIOUSLY NOT
A "WAG THE DOG" SCENARIO BECAUSE
THE TIMELINE DOESN'T MARRY UP.
>> IT'S UNREALISTIC TO EXPECT
THAT THE MEDIA IS NOT GOING TO
SEE THE POSSIBILITIES HERE.
I WANT HIM TO DO SOMETHING.